but actually I was yesterday when I looked
Many of the groups saw them very
misinformed and I'm honest I saw
I did not see what you call
Sometimes that cool substance today I see
another theme different
I feel that they already have concrete ideas
they already have good elements
grounded there are things that yes really
they will serve us what we are
looking for our entire ecosystem
I think the contribution is going to be gigantic and
I think that there is not going to be a single
winner but I think they will have 10
winning groups and I'm really very
happy because I know that the results
they are going to be giants
really good thank you very much many
thanks paco we were watching there
quickly what happened with this nursery
but 2013 we are going to go a cut like this very
quickly because the challenge is coming
let's complete the challenge let's
follow of course with
the presentation of each of the
groups and with much more money but 2013
edition so seconds already we come back with
much more
Hello my name is Guillermo León
angel business group
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there are no people in the
group simply we are all very good
in what we are doing and joining
forces here to finish fast today
I spoke with Guillermo Gómez I am from the group
of 7 is very count percent but
we have the certainty changes every morning and
we have all contributed many things
important in the group but I rescue
to our partner who has a lot
knowledge and has not contributed too much
much more thank you very much
good afternoon no man is july
makes the area part of the group
recycled
we carry an approximate 75 percent
of the project and therefore
we consider our genius
It has always been our project manager
who was he
who originated the idea good my name
is Ricardo Chiriboga from the group of
agronomy
I think
the one that has given the most in the group
It has been between the designer and the project
made because they have tried to guide us
us about the idea my friend didier
is taking care of the front part
end and 40%
well good we continue in this video you
tried 2003 and scion bogota comes the
presentation of the groups comes the
presentation of each of the
solutions all that devotional innovation
list and available for you there
connected that barbara are you happy
very happy little voice I'm going through very
good in you good very good look let's go to
review quickly because there is grace
number of messages now our
social focus and we remember quickly
we remembered payments that can not continue
may well join the community
developers that can follow the
plage page by supposed developers
google put more one according to the
circles because we have so many
information for you talk a lot
with us nor god
where is the hidden camera the
developer where is the spy camera
hidden
we are going to look for it so attentive
because you can also determine where
where would you like more than this one
camera is that I'm looking a little at
see what is happening here in the
kitchen so we go to ccoo I know that
there are many messages in the social network to
see what is happening many messages
nor what not
hector are raising passions in
Mexico will particularly make days
says ready to support talent
Colombian and water for daniela del
tram
but there's competition gets better than
the clear
if he had the beltrán it is very pretty but
that has now developed in love
how are you these Mexicans that bars
they are all Mexican it is true to say
what a good barbarian while francisco
continues analyzing the beni social network
keep going because we have had
speaking today, it's our turn
talk about big query if we are
speaking that is a bank scenario
massive data or to analyze bank of
massive cars that is good to consult
yes that is not so optimal because we have
other cloud solutions to perform
insertions editions and different types
of activities that the biggest advantage
is to combine the infrastructure plus the
platform and also use biker and you
I say the challenge I tell you again I repeat
you have to use the birth chart and
that a public table that proposes
leather and from that table tell us how many
How many records are women in Mexico
it was very easy in Mexico they did it in
a second while flying you're solving
and connected
us on this final day of day 2 of
back end because we had still tomorrow
the reward more if I go looking for two
participants yes you can earn a
prize of course because we have
possibilities but I will look for the
bottom groups if you think
or go by if you look how it happened
working come with me
seeing the man over there in gray let's see
if I can get here the lord of the body
come, come, you are going to see you come
over here they were going to be a challenge over
My neck wants to put some of its
developers as one of its developers
send me one of your level
that's working great more than one of
its developers man from our developers
whoever wants
to see who comes and goes the group here
the since I see them that the iata comes
one of its developers who is encouraged
sit down well which easy traditional sql
we are talking about the table of
birth who is encouraged who comes
come on here, come on, come with me
forward a strong applause accompany me
look how come we are going to interview here
just mister cristian as it comes for the
sql
prepared and look that you can win
something very interesting so now we're going
to see who came from the
group developers none what
they leave it vacant in the lord
good perfect come join me for
here come here come with me here
come here we are doing very
we quickly have their successes we are
watching we are seeing good good
perfect no no no to look here much more
what we have what we have to do
then it is to make a query and now
we have to consult the table of
birth rate and know how many women have
and what am I going to give him the opportunity
first this one yes
and against the birth until the
structure you can quickly see a
help vocecita and for the whole life well
there is an attribute look out there
already tac tac tac look at that mail
we can look for any other to see if
is that you prefer like you
want if they can use query
quick I have to tell the lord first
if we have to count how many records
they are women of that birth chart
we quickly started counting 25
seconds from now voices and tote for
that we follow 25 24 223 we want to put it
nervous 22 21 20 18 8 15
I have the horn 14 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
and there we are going to let him steal
wants to give him lion rope
He did not work, sir.
opportunity to see let's see how it comes
the hand then
as you want to see the long the
net
very well very well and yes yes yes yes
perfect keep thinking we are going to give
20 seconds because the lady is like
has already lost some time so 20
seconds let's start counting from
here because you want to modify the code
earlier yes so the 2010 1918 and yes
this is for a trip to silicon valley 14
which also has a combination with no
new york so 10 and 14 3 good for
go to london of course 10 98
the fault, good, thank you very much
sadly I fail
thank you very much the next dinner seems
that Mexico was better prepared I do not
I want to say nothing in this but good if
is a little bit we are going to leave the
question whether we take the value
of the social network because the people in the
social network
of course you can still solve the
question so let's wait for
see what our mentors say
virtual our mental developers
payments if you think we are preparing
prepare for the presentation and ready
ready all ready all are all
ready so we took but some
seconds a few seconds nothing more and already
we come with the presentation of each one
of the groups where you're going to see all the
innovation from this nursery questions and
what seconds we heat engines and already
we go with much more fun
my name is guillermo lion of the group
business angel
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python as
crazy and I think there are no people in the
group
we are all simply very good at what
what are we doing and joining forces
here to finish fast was the best
guillermo gómez I am from group 7
we are 40 percent but we have the
certainty that I am finished tomorrow and all
We have all contributed many things
important in the group but I rescue
to our partner who has a lot
knowledge and no help contributed
too much much more thank you
good afternoon not a name is July
Cesar Arzo I am part of the group recycles
Well, we have an approximate of 75
percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
it has always been our project manager
who was he
that who originated the idea good my
name is ricardo chiriboga
the agronomy group
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager have
tried to guide us on the
idea my friend
Didier is taking care of the part
of the front end and the backend submits you to
what promises us 40 percent we
lack is to put the services at
bridge so that person from fernando
william lion of the group and the business
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python to the
crazy and I think that
well we're still in this nursery
probos 2000 decision bogotá reaches the
presentation of the applications reaches
the presentation of the groups paco I am
very excited to see the breakthrough for
this second day not like that is nick and ya
we have the number one team ready here
alejandro all yours we coppel to how
they are and good
Diana no longer asked for a loan in a
cooperative she finds out that she has to
leave for two months from the city
she can only pay the fees
your credit at the place where you asked for it
just like her there are more than 5 million
users who can present this same
problem to do before
that's why I do not know how
cooperate solution to a real problem and
it does not create a need
is available anywhere in the
world you are inside or outside your city
In addition, the cooperatives at the
worldwide work under the same model
the cooperative team has the
knowledge
facilitates the exchange of products and
services between cooperatives between
users and between cooperatives and users
So far what we have
worked is this is our image
corporate
please the next
we already have an application that
you can see on a website and in addition to
we are working on our
web application the entire structure of
this application is contained in the
next way is an application
scalable is a highly application
available that is mounted on it
in the app engine uses the data store
is developed in the web framework
app written in python we use that
to communicate with the different
dispositives
cloud points we use a framework that
it's called lungo and besides that
we use something from the client side that
it's called to turn
thank you very much very well loud applause
then to cooperate thank you very much
what barbarian paco what good presentation
it was a presentation and we are going to make them
a brief comment now from the party
technological some of our mentors
here they have been doing evaluation of
all your code we are going to give you a
average of what we think they have in
this moment so that you have an idea
know that you can improve between today and
tomorrow for you in particular they go
very well they have a 2.83 on average in
this scale from 1 to 5
then technically speaking it's a
solid product but can still
round up some details between today and
tomorrow very well thanks and congratulations
then thank you very much Alejandro
neither is our group the number
2 does not add up
let's look then here we have the
presentation quickly we are going to
looking for group number two is here
it is not true the 11 minutes
minutes ago and it's coming
ok or the nights I'm going to talk to you
little more than what we have already developed
we are in 70 percent we can already
deploy applications in the cloud and in
own domain in fact if you can
happen
let's hear
the stem that appears when from
our app and good and our page
web that we have running the
applications automatically creates a
instance and the first screen is what
they receive in the domain that we
we provide this is what topication is
ready to spray is simply to throw
the first clip and you can already have your
own as you can enter these
pages and see it running the
page as it is current of our
up is what is going to be today
at night 7 and tomorrow but already the
functioning as such is then already
the difficult step and it became easy
and that is practically our
direct competition and is hosted in
amazon which is the direct competition of
club then practically a
competition
but that has two million
applications running over two thousand of
applications then why not
use this in the servers of
Google
a strong applause for the group
If you want to try it tomorrow clear
that yes clear that yes to approve is to apply
acts to contain their valuations and
we have a valuation in reality this
is the team that is most advanced
technically he is the one who has the
qualification at this time highest
3.83 which is very good we are
talking about a competition also from
see the agility of the team to
implement solutions then they go very
well you have to round up I guess that part
of the concept for the part let's say of
sale and the impact for SMEs that is
let's say like the subject here but very
well solid the loud applause the
highest technological evaluation
speaking really good they will have psycho
I'm really pleasantly surprised
surprised because having solutions
awesome really so like that so
we continue to see the team 3
let's go with the team 3 yes hopefully the
presentation of team 3 that we have
we all remember if both in the
repositor team 3 23 minutes ago
here no bis plus
there we go with big blues
the previous one ok
to see if they help me see which of
all because 24 minutes dry
you tell me group three days two
times
I ask myself and I answer myself
cordial greeting our project is
he calls bis plus that is
and promote strategic alliances
among SMEs
respect how that platform works is
a responsible website is going to be able to see
any device and on the platform
the following scheme is handled
that the person enters the page can
locate SMEs that may have the
same product and they suddenly have
the flaws in different aspects
as a company can then move to a
part that integrates t which is where the
first can relate and negotiate
your products or can share the
flaws weaknesses and strengths between
them and projects that is finally what
that you are looking for a partnership to generate
projects that generate impact
in the sector or in the market
then as I said the
application is this and the website
actually the graphic design can be
observe that there are some specifications
of the use of these from this application is
login with the google + login and
You can also take a previous look at
the application that actually
or the most striking thing about this application
is the fact that the person enters
this page is this page place
select a sector immediately
appears SMEs that are willing to
negotiate with them to generate a
strategic alliance
then the tools that are
used so that is being used
for for this project is google + as
I was commenting on the part of
project management what is google
drive what is
hangout
perfect good a round of applause for the group
number 3
technical evaluation of technical evaluation
you are in the middle of the table
it is also a solid application has
a 2.33 are a little behind the
first group and a lot more behind the
second they go to the head but also
they still have very good possibilities
to integrate something this recommendation is
we do it to all the groups try
have your stake running tomorrow
it gives a great plus in your application something
that the judges can play using
etcetera but very well
perfect loud applause of course
again there for the group good paco h
we are seeing because he is here
we talk about football and all that and that
sometimes one wins half of the table
it's easy basically as he says
estevo says beat belgium is like
be in the middle of the table but good
matter do not worry about course
we are going to cut super fast if we
let's take a few minutes
seconds nothing more a few seconds and we're going
to go see all this innovation that
we're
the level by voice bogota edition so
we warm up engines we prepare arrive
the groups the following group the group
number 4 567 all that remain for
share with us the progress of this
second day of development and innovation
of adrenaline that have characters here
in colombia so we prepare
heated engines and we come back with a lot
more level or forgiveness 2013 Bogota edition
in the group we are simply all very
good at what we are doing and
joining forces to finish fast
gomez of group 7 we are 40% but
we have the surprise changes every morning and
we have all contributed many things
important in the group but I rescue
to our partner who has a lot
knowledge and has not contributed
too much much more thank you
good afternoon no name is july
Cesar aso I am part of the group I grew up
claps we take an approximate of 75
percent of the project and then
we consider our genius
It has always been our project manager
who was he
who originated the idea good my name
is Ricardo Chiriboga from the group of
agronomy
It seems to me that the one who has given the most
size in the group has been between
designer and the project manager because
they have tried to guide us
about the idea my friend didier is
commissioning the front end part and
the backend submitting it at 40% we are missing
is to put the services to the source for
that person of fernando consumes
good we continue in this developers
2013 Bogota edition as we are
happening payment that great we are seeing
great applications and the turn comes
of the next group then whom
we have prepared the team number 4
daniela please glove talkies
my name is diana them where are they going
who want to fulfill your wishes and
we are a team that wants
meet theirs well basically what
that seeks one tip is that being a
mobile application that allows you
Find the products you want
without you having to look for them is
say that the proposals reach tim
howard with gloves we have
come working some platforms
like google + analytics
and android
and cloud platform
maybe a little bit of the ones that never
we have had in regards to the front-end more
that everything here visually then then
how the idea works is that you
authentic entering by your google + if
you want to bid
with that offer or if you want to look for a
product you want to wish as regards liu
come out then that's how the
visualization of liu being we were doing
some categories and you in those categories
you're basically going to set some parameters
as your budget the colors and the
object in particular the product in
particular you want and the dimensions
What do you want us to do?
very social and that you can share
with your friends and they can give you
recommendations by the other side of the
click on the client then you will see
also as a player some categories of
products and the wish lists of the
people who have asked you what you
you offer the idea is that then that you like
company you can reach exactly is in
that specific niche of the market that
want what you
applause for the group number 42
thank you jana also value rating
super good work are tied in a
third place they have three points in the
scale from 1 to 5 very well and is the only
to where I have in my notes the only
what is an application of
native android ok extra point for by
accountants are strong applaud team
number 5 well the number 5 we will look for
your presentation that is already loaded here
pre-loaded day 2 no match point
salt at 5
good evening we are more today
what identifies is a problem the
problem we have is that there are SMEs
who have needs and there are bidders
who have products and services and are
looking for clients then the solution
we propose through matchpoint is
connect those needs with those
bidders then the idea of ​​the
platform is that you enter with that
you need
when you need it and how much are you
willing to pay and different
bidders who make their best proposal
is a proposal that has to be a
balance between cost-benefit and
for each SME, choose which one is like
most important point where the currency
I prefer price I prefer time I prefer
quality already depends on each of the
specific needs of the
SME
our problem is when I eat how much
you need it
let's say our main
Differentials is
we go into needs there are many
portals that give you offers and you apply
those offers in this case the by say
that the base is I need something who
can do what I need to whom
can not supply a need once the
satisfies let's say there's a process of
auction in reverse and is that you say
when you need it and how much are you
willing to pay and the people that you
offer something they offer you according to that offer
maximum that maximum price that you gave what
that helps the cost go away
reducing and in a market like those
SMEs where we all say that the costs
are so essential and the idea is that you
reduce your expenses as an auction to the
reverse is a huge benefit and the
scale and scalability because it serves
for all types of SMEs from a
bakery to a technology company
any type of SMEs may need
services and on this platform is going to
find someone who is willing to
meet those needs that have
very good loud applause
good incident with a good pitch
we also have this team in a great
second place technically speaking they have
done a very solid job they go very well
so for her we have several
competitors that they should put them to
everyone to think they have to climb their
level of applications but they go well and
good for not that because
let's imagine the vuce quoted that says
you need the 5 liters of fuel or 50
liters as we use to pay so much
well there could not buy much but
ok we could ok come on then
with group number 6
ok let's see 6 day 2 a yale business comes
or
it's very big says ok it's a problem with
group 6
ok come on let's go with the group number 77
of course of course we make a
change at the end day 2 arrive
working ants of group 7 a
the ants
is an application that allows
first it is based on several technologies of
concord as are the sun
autos analytics is an application in
base for android for web application
because there are several SMEs that do not
they have android also keeps it with
google maps and used the technology of
maine cakes that also uses google and
well the idea of ​​the general problem is
that several SMEs do not necessarily
they have contacts with the outside or with
merchants apart then what
we do in general is a
solution the solution that we generate is
a channel of dialogue that can
allow you to manage that you can
allow grow that you can afford
expand as well as get others
business that would not normally get
the business model itself is based on
a platform that can contain data
that can get that analysis of
market just as it can offer
products and distributors
and can attract other goods and others
products that are not available in the
current market
seen thank you very much payton with the
absence of phenomena 7
technical evaluation and technical evaluation
is that as you can see they also have
a plethora of tools and apis of
google are tied was the draw
that we have in the third place
technically speaking they go very well and
well I think the product is
relatively stable the pitch could
improve a little concentration doing it
more attractive but it seems to me that
Congratulations are going very well too
perfect perfect and we remember by
course we have group number 6 already
prepared but we also remember that
all these applications can see them
because they are in the public repository
permanently they are updated and
they see so we go then with the
group number 6 onwards that
comes there the business now is now
so speed voice hits
I'm part of the team beyond business
my name is christian palau and
basically what we have identified is
that SMEs have grown in a way
informal and that informality lane the an
in their organizational culture that has
subtracted competitiveness to them
we have to do carlos sorry that makes
part of an SME and he wants to improve his
project development process for
your clients what's up with that he
It is part of 12 thousand 650 SME companies
in colombia that do not use the tic's
precisely for the development of
projects as such that as I already know
I said before it reduces competitiveness
because the tic's today makes it faster
much the processes what is our
objective to potentiate three pillars
fundamentals within the organization
competitiveness innovation and the
growth of SMEs how are we going to
do we have three phases the first one is
develop through an interface that
It is didactic and easy to use
platform that uses scrum that is for
develop projects the second phase
It is a phase that what it seeks is to improve
the process of generating innovation or
innovation within MSMEs and the
third phase is precisely through
metrics that they play and increase
or can have growth
through the metrics within the
organ within the platform for the
first phase we have developed the
first part that the development of
projects as I told you has a
interface that is very very easy to use
there for them that what they do is that
believe it and in this case Carlos has
four projects then that are going to
go managing little by little and you will go
showing the metrics of all of his
all your side from what there is
developing he's going to have there that
integrated air with all its
teammates and on their smartphone
they will be able to see the advances of
kout as we have done it then team
developer that is a hard one on this
they have integrated four fundamental things
the application that will be available
already entered a few moments the beta phase of
the application is available on the play
store
is available on android football
storage we have the calendar so that
can continue to watch their progress within
of each project and we have the google to
pyongyang
finally our great team of
work that seriously has been excellent
a guard applause for Eurasia group and
also covering technical assessment
thanks cristian let's go before doing
quickly a cut I want to tell you that
watching the presentation and what we know
technically from you like there's no
a match are quite more qualified
having 1.6 and that's because
they are probably not raising their
code in time to the repository and not
are giving you an opportunity to evaluate it
but they have everything tonight and the day of
tomorrow to put it there and show us
all this that looks pretty good
perfect low excellent already well in the
presentation of the following groups
but I'm not going to take a few seconds to
some seconds to tell you very
suddenly the amount of message that
we have thank you to andres a anna
which is connected of course angel
although the vote one of those from the
participants
permanently writing in the
social approach and promote
other applications
another of the teachings this nursery but
bosch 2013 of course can
promote the application is all
latin america looking at them so many
thanks for staying connected like this with
with all the innovation that we are
watching here so to ccoo us
we took a few seconds and we're back with
much more free but with 2013 edition already
we will see
Hello my name is Guillermo León
group there business
we go more or less to 20% of the back end
because we are learning python to the
crazy and I think there are no people in the
group simply we are all very good
what we are doing and joining
forces here to finish fast
gómez I am from group 7 we are 40%
but we are lucky we get to each
tomorrow and we all have all contributed
many important things in the group
but I rescue our companion that
who has a lot of knowledge and has not
contributed too much much more many
Thank you
good afternoon no man is july
Cesar Arzo I am part of the group
recycled
we carry an approximate 75 percent
of the project
follow the presentation group number 88 and
progressively they followed us on their side
we do not need a presentation
we have a live product alive and so
we are going to demonstrate to all Latin America
here live set for the audience
also how it works so go ahead
good night, my name is fabian
zapata and belong to the recycling group
as they already knew how to recycle
application that allows us to manage
all this electronic waste that does not
they serve us as people
natural or private companies that
They do not know what to do with them
be a solution through the
platform where you can post that
electronic element that does not serve you and
probably to another person if it serves
somewhere then is how to generate
the profiles we have advance then
something the landing page where there is
information
in the registry we can register a
user register a company then
in the registry of a user we are going to
make an example mode to put
and this is an area of ​​opportunity for
google + haining
totally one click
click and more and ready
Exactly clear is that we need to have
data such as personal data for
identify what in people
they are identified
along with oops running against the
time was not
he closed all of us all the bronze
that could close iron
I am a woman who has worked
but
60 because it was awful now how are we going
to return to retake 2013 you have to recycle
the only one is not more than the semifinal
you can come the horn
if I do not want to have to put me
here it can come out like the hammer blow of
mechanic
all because it may not be the
platform is saying we are
transmitting all the information from
the portal if from your computer
reports the pod then then
to register us because it identifies the
current location where are we going to
publish the waste then in that device
electronic that is that it no longer serves us
then one could post any
thing
yes yes yes it can be something
It is also going out of fashion
good
they have the possibility of moving forward
so we give it a loud applause group
number 80 and register and have a route
where then by means of fusion tables
verify the exact ones and following the route
you are working here and you are sleeping
a group perfectly thank you very much
we go with the group number 9 that in
some time we are going to enter the
presentations to see if they let me do
a little more
ok let's go to
ok here have presentations ok
while it looks like a wonder
quickly to see that he helps me with the
group number 9 because I do not see it very like that
down down
we will see that
but well let's go forward agro
Goodnight
It was nice she has a farm on her farm
she has cows and she has pigs she wants
get vaccine for your cows and
food and wants to put on sale their
pigs were usually resorts to where
today Miguel and buy the vaccine if the
food for your backs
and use the voice to voice method to
market your pigs when you go
back home a neighbor says juanita
you have already tried agronomy
agronomy agronomy is an interface
web and mobile that allows the user
in the reference inputs of what is
is trading in the livestock sector to
regional level
as we can see our three types
fundamental is to locate suppliers and
products close to us is
find according to your budget and the
another is to establish a supplier relationship
with the seller this with that phil yo
I'm looking for products of the best
quality and I always look for the premise cost
quality with this application we are
focused on being premise in the sector
The country is very important
take into account this equation and to our
part technical development with which
we count on paper and we're
using at point to connect the
mobile application then with the server
It should be clarified in the upper part
we have the mobile application initially
only for users and web registration
for suppliers this with what purpose
the provider will upload data and goes the
program about contents to our
applications that's why we developed it
emphatically web since it is then
profile as likes android location
and the pre wars that we are working
thank you
the technical relationship so that we have the
equipment for the previous team
it was extremely fast
we do not have a lot of misinformation either
online are very poorly qualified
fact they are the last team in terms
technicians because we have not really seen
how everything is implemented that we
they showed here working then
make sure we can understand what
what they have there for you go
pretty good then we say that
message also that we always talk
keep programming
they continue program and they are programming
then they say programming also good
we go with group number 10 then
sorry he started the 10 for
agronomy, you are doing quite well
they are there in the middle of the table as in
fourth place 267 it looks solid its
application
we did the validation of the
application with a user he is
interested in investing in the platform
and the knowledge propose them the
explanations the next 30
interesting ok let's see then
let's talk a lot more on the day of
tomorrow with you to see what it is about
that story we keep working
here in this proven nursery you know
totally live so it has come with the
group number 10
Good evening, today
we work on three fronts
one then the first and the most important
the back in on the package as we are
taking advantage of everything that the
app engine and also the data storage
Additionally, we wanted to improve a
little French design
taking into account then that we change a
little of the logo we change also the
pages where you're going to access let's say the
employer when you are looking for
initiative where we focus strongly on
today was to validate our model
of business we did an investigation of
market looking at what our
possible competitors and we find therefore
that the competition is really strong
but we believe that we have a plus
taking into account that we what
we want to generate is welfare to
teleworker we basically want
solve three problems that is
generate well-being by bringing the worker
generate added value to the employer
that uses teleworking as a
initiative so you can take advantage
better your infrastructure resources
and generate access to different
work modalities through the
telework initiative we found
for example curious facts that in the
most countries at the
Latin American have standards that
encourage teleworking and regulations that
let's say they provide benefits for
implement these initiatives was also
the figures that show the markets of
teleworking because they are quite attractive
for example in the case of Brazil in the
now we find that there are 10.8
millions of active teleworkers
and barely 10% of the population in
what could be the object of our
our project here because there are the
validations
loud applause for the group
very well very well is an idea
interesting indeed there is a lot
a lot of competition in that market
technically they go very well having a
233 of 5 and a little bit through the
leaders but that's a good one good
technical solution because I think we've already seen
all groups and today we are talking
just from elba that everyone did their
presentation there were better pitchers that
others have care tomorrow
work a lot with you in that part
because they have to achieve quality to sell
your product will then have to
pitch all the people there
outside and the judges no no to us
they are exactly exactly so
thank you very much also for sharing
this technological dynamism that
we have here so we only have left
minutitos so that I think that we
we have seen a great few minutes
number of innovative projects
we have given a technical evolution to the
mentors have worked
impressively we want to thank you
the invention all the mentors also
to all that audience that is
accompanying a lot and the resolution
of the challenge they made
also shared between joel and adam there
so we're going to be contacting the
also to see to see good let's see
how can we call them tomorrow and
go live of course so I'll
thank you, look for the amount
of messages arming andrés good
mercedes also andres mejía where
can see the andres repository where
you can see the repository we have it
free it's called developer bus ya you what
let's share through the class
page also to whom in a comment
so you can of course enjoy
of all this technological adrenaline
of all this proposed innovation votes
payment we are going to greet the public
we finished thank you very much it was a great
day thanks to all the teams are
working very well congratulations if they go
better than mexico and argentina
Thank you
to all who accompany us this is
nursery 2013 Bogota edition as well as
we have tomorrow from very early
we come back with these three lines
technological and the final message is follow
programming we'll see you tomorrow until
morning